malgré des tensions et des crises qui
les divise
ailleurs dans le monde six grandes
puissances les états unis la chine la
russie le royaume uni l'allemagne et la
france négocie depuis près d'un an avec
la république islamique iranienne
on veut éviter que l'iran ait la
capacité de produire une arme nucléaire
l'iran aurait beaucoup à gagner d'une
éventuelle entente
son économie est lourdement grevés par
des sanctions des etats-unis de l'union
européenne et de l'onu ces revenus du
pétrole sont en chute libre
le taux d'inflation et frôle les 15 % le
taux de chômage y reste élevé ces
sanctions la faune très très mal à lire
elles font de plus en plus mal mais
c'est un effet cumulatif qui
s'accumulent avec les années alors s'il
n'y avait pas d'accord
cette année ou l'an prochain dans deux
ans dans quatre ans a commencé à faire
très mal
le président obama a lui aussi tout à
gagner d'un éventuel accord
il a écrit au moins à trois reprises au
guide suprême de la révolution
l'ayatollah kameni pour le rassurer lui
expliquant que les grandes puissances ne
voulait pas écraser les rentes mais bien
lui permettre de rejoindre la communauté
internationale des femmes le président
obama n'a pas obtenu de grands succès en
politique étrangère surtout pas au
moyen-orient c'est de plus en plus clair
que le président obama a besoin de
laisser un héritage derrière lui besoin
de de pouvoir montrer que des dossiers
au niveau international sur lesquels il
a mis son empreinte de façon permanente
clairement le dossier nucléaire iranien
ce serait quelque chose ça serait son
héritage principal au niveau
international
ottawa ces jours ci l'ambassade de
l'iran au canada est déserte
derrière les grilles c'est le silence en
2012 devant le refus de l'iran de se
conformer aux résolutions de l'onu sur
son programme nucléaire
le gouvernement harper a mis fin à ses
relations avec l'iran
rompre les relations diplomatiques en
diplomatie c'est un non sens c'est qu'on
garde toujours une porte ouverte
ce dialogue rompu préoccupe michel de
salaberry l'ancien ambassadeur du canada
en iran il a été à même de constater
l'écart entre de régime iranien et les
désirs de sa population mais aussi la
nouvelle dynamique qui semble
s'installer à l'intérieur du pays
c'est une dynamique positive que le
pouvoir iranien sentent la pression
populaire pour pour réintégrer la
communauté internationale c'est le
sentiment populaire qui veut l'ouverture
mais c'est aussi la situation économique
qui rend urgent de pouvoir retourner sur
les marchés internationaux
si on arrive à une entente les grandes
puissances espèrent que cela mènera un
rôle plus actif de l'iran pour ramener
la paix dans cette partie du monde
ils estiment les iraniens et ce n'est
pas nouveau ça ne date même pas de la
révolution islamique
les iraniens estiment que leur pays est
une puissance internationale qui a été
exclu du panthéon des grandes puissances
mais il estime aujourd'hui qu'il doit
que ce pays doit retrouver sa place
légitime dans ce club des grandes
puissances l'iran chiite beaucoup d'
influence auprès de l'irak de la syrie
et du liban où il financé armes le
groupe armé hezbollah l'iran pourrait
aider à combattre le groupe armé l'état
islamique qui menace toute la région
donc son voisinage mais bien des
obstacles se dressent pour bloquer un
accord des pays arabes comme l'arabie
saoudite les états du golfe persique
redoute de voir l'iran joue un rôle
prépondérant dans leur voisinage à
brisbane
le premier ministre israélien benyamin
netanyahu exige le démantèlement complet
du programme nucléaire iranien
un point c'est tout doucement mixte est
à vérone
le maroc vient des membres du congrès
américain réclament aussi un
démantèlement complet de ce programme
nucléaire depuis que les ayatollahs ont
plus de pouvoir dans la république
islamique d'iran en 1979
les etats-unis ont du mal à faire
confiance à ce régime
c'est toujours ce problème de méfiance
mutuelle de scepticisme qui a été
accumulée au cours des 35 dernières
années et qui ne va certainement pas se
dissiper
du jour au lendemain on ne se fait pas
confiance et on a tout le temps
l'impression de part et d'autre qui a un
agenda caché
du côté iranien des durs dans
l'entourage de l'ayatollah khamenei et
les gardiens de la révolution une
organisation paramilitaire du régime
islamique s'oppose à tout compromis sur
le nucléaire ce qui pourrait faire
pencher la balance dans tout ça c'est
que les iraniens ont élu un président
plus tôt mode et v hassan rohani qui
peut plaider en faveur d'un accord mais
l'iran veut arracher le plus grand
nombre de concessions avant d'y arriver
de ce point de vue là il se laisse
désirer et savent que les opportunités
économiques que qu'impliquerait
normalisation des relations avec l'iran
intéresse tellement la communauté
internationale que d'autres occasions se
présenteront les américains et leurs
alliés hésitent à envoyer à nouveau des
troupes combattre en irak et dans la
région une région où l'iran pourrait à
nouveau jouer un rôle de grande
puissance
si on arrive à un accord sur son
programme nucléaire